eine besonderer tag gobbi ist tot
michael gorbatschow der letzte
sowjetpräsident der letzte noch lebende
vater der deutschen einheit er ist nach
langer krankheit gestorben und wir sagen
heute danke für sein lebenswerk für das
lebenswerk von michael gorbatschow dem
man die wir ein denkmal gesetzt haben
bei uns vom springer haus dieses denkmal
die büste von michael gorbatschow seit
2010 also seit über zwölf jahren
mittlerweile begrüßt sie uns jeden
morgen auf dem weg zur arbeit ganz in
der nähe von dort wo einst die mauer
stand die büste der kopf des mannes der
so sehr geholfen hat diese mauer
einzureißen und gorbatschow seinen kopf
dort neben mit dem kopf von helmut kohl
und dem von george bush die köpfe der
deutschen einheit die väter der
deutschen einheit gorbatschow bush und
natürlich kohl und wir sprechen hier
gleich bei welt live mit dem kohl sohn
mit walter kohl über seine ganz
besonderen persönlichen erinnerung mit
michael gorbatschow und die erinnerungen
an seinen vater an die väter der
deutschen einheit ja und wir sprechen
natürlich mit ihm dann gleich den sohn
helmut kohls über das lebenswerk von
michael gorbatschow über dieses
lebenswerk
kann ein einziger man die welt verändern
ja
er hat uns deutschen die einheit
geschenkt er hat es geschafft den
eisernen vorhang zu durchbrechen ohne
blutvergießen
seine lebensleistung wir verneigen uns
dort
michael gorbatschow der mann mit dem
feuer mal auf der stirn sein
berühmtester satz wer zu spät kommt den
bestraft das leben
gesagt angeblich am 6 oktober 1989 in
ostberlin zu ddr staatschef honecker die
berühmteste botschaft an gorbatschow
diese vom damaligen us-präsidenten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
mister gorbatschow er tat genau das er
ließ mauern einreißen
gorbatschow strammer kommunist in den
70ern steigt dem sowjetischen
machtapparat steil auf er
1985 das riesige land führt hinein in
reformen glasnost offenheit
perestroika umgestaltung
das ist gorbatschow
[Musik]
die sowjetunion schwach fällt der putz
1991 auch gorbatschow nun weg
im westen ist er ein held
im heutigen russland für viele ein
verräter bis heute
gorbatschow lebte zurückgezogen den tod
seiner geliebten frau raissa im jahr
1999 überwand er nieder
[Musik]
selbst seit vielen jahren schwer krank
nun gestorben
wir verneigen uns
michael gorbatschow danke gott
[Musik]
und wir freuen uns sehr dass jetzt
weiter kohle bei uns ist er ist
unternehmer er ist autor und er ist der
sohn des früheren bundeskanzlers helmut
kohl des kanzlers der einheit einen
schönen guten morgen ihnen
sie sind michael gorbatschow mehrfach
begegnet wie haben sie diese begegnung
in wahrgenommen
ich habe diese begegnung natürlich im
kontext der damaligen zeit wahrgenommen
wir kamen aus dem kalten krieg und das
wichtigste war dass mein vater dass
george bush und auch michael gorbatschow
verstanden haben dass krieg kein mittel
für politik für zusammenarbeit für
koexistenz ist ganz wichtig auch alle
drei haben selber kriegserfahrungen
gorbatschow mein vater als jugendlicher
george bush als pilot der amerikanischen
navy im pazifik sie wüssten was krieg
und verderben heißt wir vertiefen das
gleich politisch herr kohl aber diesen
mann sind sie auch so persönlich
begegnet die familien waren wirklich
miteinander eng wirklich befreundet also
was hat für sie den menschen michael
gorbatschow ausgemacht
sein mut dass er gesagt hat in der
realen situation in den 80er jahren die
sowjetunion das damalige system braucht
reformen dass es sich gegen den
zeitgeist in der begründung der erkannt
hat wenn ich das richtig machen will
dann aushalten dann muss ich das
durchstehen mut und aushalten sin zwei
qualitäten die ich mit gorbatschow
verbindet sie waren 26 bei der einheit
sie sind michael gorbatschow mehrfach
begegnet wir haben sie auch als sohn des
kanzlers der einheit diesen ganzen
prozess diese historische welt
veränderung wahrgenommen
es war natürlich kein prozess der von
vornherein geplant war niemand wusste
was passieren wird ich erinnere nur an
die botschaften in die situation in den
botschaften in prag in budapest das
paneuropäische picknick für mich war ein
schlüsselmoment die zehn punkte
deklaration meines vaters die
richtungsweisend divisionär war und
natürlich die öffnung des brandenburger
tors dass damit auch letztlich die
öffnung der mauer unumkehrbar geworden
ist kurz vor weihnachten 1989 danach in
den frühen monaten des jahres 1990 die
zwei plus vier verhandlungen waren
voller schwierigkeiten voller haken und
ösen wenn ich das so sagen darf und da
hat sich eben gezeigt ist das
persönliche vertrauen und die
menschliche klarheit zwischen
gorbatschow george bush und mein vater
letztlich eine politische grundlage
geschaffen hat auf basis dessen was die
menschen in der damaligen ddr geleistet
haben an zivilen widerstand an aufstehen
gegen ein system unmut was ist abgesehen
von den großen großen politischen zielen
was ist das erbe von michael gorbatschow
das menschliche erbe vielleicht etwas
von dem wir alle in der heutigen zeit
lernen können
wir können von gorbatschow und ab
letztlich von seiner frau denn seine
frau war immer auch teil seiner politik
cia den ganz wesentlich getragen
lernen dass krieg kein mittel ist und
das ist ja im heutigen machtapparat von
wladimir putin überhaupt nicht die
diskussion
und da zeigt sich eben dass ein mann der
als jugendlicher den zweiten weltkrieg
erlebt hat der erlebt hat welches
grausame schmerzen welche grausam
schmerz das auch für die eigene familie
bedeutet der eben weiß dass krieg kein
mittel in europa ist und wir können
mutlangen von ihm nicht armut ist die
wichtigste qualität die wir heute in der
jetzigen situation brauchen auch wenn es
schwierigkeiten gibt wir haben hier
heute genügend schwierigkeiten inflation
gas energiekrise und so weiter und so
fort war wirtschaft kurs gehalten er hat
seine reformen insbesondere glasnost und
perestroika große widerstände und ich
finde wenn toni lernen können ist es
dass das was wir als richtig erkannt
haben nämlich freiheit und demokratie
entschieden durchzusetzen und zu
verteidigen wir leben nun den ganz
anderen zeiten in kriegszeiten ich weiß
das ist rein spekulativ aber diese
beiden staatsmänner die sich dann auch
eben persönlich irgendwann so nahe waren
wenn wir solche männer noch an der
spitze hätten die sich eben persönlich
auch so nah sind würden wir dann heute
in kriegszeiten leben
das kann man schlecht sagen was man
sagen kann ist der staat zwischen meinem
vater und michael gorbatschow war ja
alles andere als harmonisch ich denke
nur den goebbels vergleich und ähnliche
dinge aber sie haben sich im besten sinn
des wortes zusammengerauft sie haben
sich gefunden und sie sind beide in der
lage gewesen über alte ideologische
stellen zu gehen und zu sagen wir
stellen das wohl der menschen in den
vordergrund vor machtpolitischem kalkül
dass dies mit mir putin heute nicht
möglich ist der uns über jahre
hintergangen und belogen hat ist wohl
klar insofern kann man das als situation
nicht vergleichen man kann es als
hoffnungsschimmer sehen und man kann
sagen es ist kein automatismus dass
westeuropa dass deutschland in
feindschaft mit russland leben muss ganz
im gegenteil die zeit von gorbatschow
von george bush senior und meinem vater
zeigt einklang gemeinsame ziele
gemeinsame weg es sind möglich und am
ende des kriegs und am ende der
konfrontation muss eine neue zeit mit
gorbatschow ähnlichen
gemeinsamkeiten stehen das ist meine
große hoffen das ist so schwer dass in
diesen tagen so zu sehen als
hoffnungsschimmer putin war damals einer
der aufstrebenden männer irgendwo weit
hinter gorbatschow für diesen zeiten
heute macht er das was er tut er führt
seit mittlerweile mehr als sechs monaten
einen brutalen krieg in der ukraine und
sie sagen ein hoffnungsschimmer ist dass
diese drei männer die welt zu verändern
konnten mit einem festen glauben an
frieden auch vor allen dingen in diesen
zeiten muss man nicht aber sagen das
erbe gorbatschows dass das trägt zwar
weiter hier in deutschland das ist nach
wie vor unbestritten der mauerfall die
wiedervereinigung aber das erbe
gorbatschows ist in russland eben auch
putin der zerfall der sowjetunion so
sehen dass viele russen
ich würde sagen putin ist das erbe von
heldts die nicht so
sind in ihrem land wien heute am tag
eins die generalamnestie für alle e
mails korruptions themen belasten also
da bin ich nicht ganz bei ihnen wenn sie
jetzt mal ziehen in die zeit 1905 180
1984 also jahre vor dem mauerfall jahre
vor der deutschen wiedervereinigung wo
das alles nicht vorstellbar war wo es
wirklich ein höhepunkt des kalten
krieges im sinne des nato
doppelbeschlusses gab hat auch niemand
geglaubt dass es eine lösung in fünf in
sechs jahren geben kann die eben damals
unvorstellbar und ich reserviere mir die
hoffnung wenn sie so wollen dass es auch
eine zeit nach putin geben wird dass
russland an sich nicht unser feind ist
ist dass putin ist unser feind das
müssen wir sehr sorgfältig unterscheiden
wir müssen auch verstehen dass viele der
probleme eben auf dem machthunger und
der brutalität und auch der kriminalität
des system putins kommen das müssen wir
durchstehen das müssen wir siegen
gemeinsam dort müssen wir siegen
gemeinsam mit der ukraine gemeinsam mit
unseren westlichen freundin und dann
werden wieder andere zeiten kommen putin
ist nicht das ende der zeit er ist eine
episode eine episode des verderbens der
lüge und der korruption was würde helmut
kohl was würde ihr vater was würde der
papa heute sagen
zur situation in der ukraine man sehen
oder zu was dem tod von michael
gorbatschow
ja gut er würde sagen ein guter freund
ist gegangen und das würde ich natürlich
menschlich genauso schwer belasten wie
seinerzeit der tod von george bush weil
man eben auch extreme erlebnisse und
extreme entscheidungen und extreme wege
gegangen ist das menschliche wäre es
sicherlich im vordergrund für ihn und
mein vater wäre mit sicherheit in setzt
über die entwicklung in europa das heißt
dass wir heute krieg mitten in europa
haben und dass wir letztlich vor einer
zeitenwende stehen wohl aber mit der
große fragezeichen ob wir die
zeitenwende und jetzt komme ich wieder
zu gorbatschow zurück mit dem
notwendigen mut und der notwendigen
entscheiden entschiedenheit auch
wirklich konsequent umsetzen das war
walter kohl hierbei bild live der sohn
von helmut kohl über den tod von michael
gorbatschow
an diesem tag an dem die drei väter der
deutschen einheit vereint sind im himmel
[Musik]